it's a shot that can save lives the
vaccination guards against the human
papilloma virus the primary cause of
cervical cancer in 2011 Rwanda launched
a nationwide program to vaccinate
adolescent girls against HPV therefore
vaccination rate from over 90% with is
much higher than even most of the
developed countries and this shows the
great engagement and the plan the
Rwandan government has to address this
Rwandese economy has expanded quickly
over the last 20 years the current
growth rate exceeds 7 percent
the healthcare system has improved
dramatically too
residents can go to health centers or to
district hospitals if they need further
treatment funding is provided through a
Health Insurance Scheme insurance is
very important because it gives us
access to medical care it's difficult
without insurance because medical bills
are too expensive to pay on your own
weevils are could you teach oh it would
have to be someone one of the healthcare
systems showcase district hospitals is
in Butare oh it's the only one with an
oncology department women with cervical
cancer can be operated on here but even
here in Butera
the healthcare advances have their
limits patients requiring chemotherapy
and/or radiotherapy have to travel to
neighbouring Uganda the downside of
Wonders economic boom more and more
people are developing illnesses more
typical of affluent countries non
communicable diseases such as cancer
hypertension and diabetes these
illnesses were in the spotlight at the
World Economic Forum on Africa in the
Rwandan capital Kigali in mid-may they
are putting an increasing burden on
economies throughout the continent now
the problem is 80% of the burden of
cancer is in emerging economies and 5%
of the health care spending dedicated to
cancer is in emerging economies we see
you see you see precisely the dilemma
cooperation with international drugs
companies could be part of the solution
for example in Kenya's Swiss
pharmaceutical company Novartis offers
discounted drugs to treat chronic
diseases the project could be rolled out
in Rwanda the money would need to come
from the procurement agencies in the
public sector and that from
countries are from the procuring
non-governmental organizations or at one
point in time hopefully also from donors
who Anders vaccination program against
the human papillomavirus is an example
of successful international cooperation
the scheme is organized by the state
which also pays for the vaccine costs
Merck has lowered its price to five
dollars per dose
one twentieth of the normal rate the
vaccine Alliance Garvey negotiated the
deal it's a team work we had a great
support from the Minister of Education
that's really during the the day of
vaccination of a girl at school do a
special Health Day and also to tell us
who are the children not at school that
day so that we can reach them to the
community health workers the dream of
protecting an entire generation of women
from cervical cancer is becoming reality
in Rwanda and the program could be a
trailblazer for the rest of Africa